let's jump to the story about uh about
amazon and cancel culture
and uh my friends uh thank you for
tuning in to the show tonight and i'm
pretty sure this segment is going to get
us in trouble
because the internet is stupid it's very
very stupid
and just take a look at this story from
the new york post amazon tweaks app icon
after comparisons made to hitler
what psychotic person
hold on hold on i'm not saying the
people who thought this bot cardboard
box or tape on it hitler are psychotic
i'm saying the person who worked at
amazon
saw someone complaining that your box
looks like hitler
so they immediately rushed to the
graphic department said quick change it
change it
that person's a psychopath yes they
should have been like when crackpots on
the internet start screaming
that the moon is made of cheese we don't
entertain them and write books about it
and make sure they get it we say can we
get a picture of it
of the yeah can we get a picture oh yeah
it's up right now okay
you just can't see it you want to see it
yeah i want to see it
to me that looks like michael jordan
when he had the hitler mustache that's
why michael jordan had hitler you guys
don't remember that no
i know you think i'm joking because i've
been saying a lot of fake things this
episode
but michael jordan he did a whole
commercial campaign and everyone's like
why do you have a hitler mustache oh my
gosh yeah that was like a thin mustache
oh he's no you're thinking of when he
had the lip like the cool black guy like
where it's just like that no i don't
know
no he's just like right in the middle
dude oh wow he was just like
[ __ ] you know screw it i can bring it
back dude i'm michael jordan if anyone
could
it's true all right well check this out
i see michael jordan but so the new york
new york post writes
amazon has changed its new smartphone
app logo after critics said the earlier
incarnation was a dead ringer for adolf
hitler a dead ringer
a dead ringer a dead ringer no joke they
literally did look at this
one guy let me see if i can pull i'm
trying not to make a few different jokes
right now too keep it in ryan
okay so alex alex is gonna be going on
the
yeah check it out wait wait wait
alex hearn is a uk tech editor for the
guardian
and he tweeted lmao i completely missed
that amazon quietly tweaked its new icon
to make it
look less like hitler and then some
responded well i mean to see hitler's
mustache in a ripped scotch tape
one must really think of hitler all the
time because i still don't see
all that result exactly the internet
internet is too exaggerated and
everything
and someone responded it's not just
ripped scotch tape it's a ripped scotch
tape that has a similar shape
and is right on top of a smiling mouth
looks like a happy little cardboard
adolf to me
somebody responded a really funny tweet
they said yes yes the image of the
smiling happy-go-lucky hitler yeah right
everyone thinks something like
so what if they compromise and they say
they'll make it look less like hitler
but still a little bit like hitler
somebody made this picture like we don't
want it to
obviously not the doll look like hitler
you know it's yes
do you have the daily mail picture i
mean it's a picture of hitler that looks
like a gowling
wait wait somebody made a picture yeah
you can't see it unless you get up and
you can get up and look at it yeah come
on
come on just take that just be careful
with your headphones so somebody
created this image
that's a simpson hitler this guy this
guy john evans it's
john three vans on twitter's had no
excuses here
this is amazing that's a bit much
they're crossing a line yeah
smiling it could have been charlie
chaplin
there you go why didn't amazon say it
was charlie it was it was i thought it
was weird that they changed google's
address to google.ss
okay but they also changed their motto
yeah they're being evil now so
googles.com
this is uh this is this is the world we
get to inhabit
i'm so excited who complained about this
like
who cared about it it's the same people
that
do you think it was do you think it was
like a pro hitler person that was like
this looks too much like hitler and i
don't need
amazon besmirching the great ones
situations
i would never have thought it yeah never
i don't know
who hitler would not be allowing you to
use his image
to sell stuff to a certain group of
people but so so
what was it you said that if you if you
hear the dog dog whistle you're a dog
yeah dog so so you hear dog whistles all
the time i'd imagine
i mean we're all sort of trained to hear
all the things right now so it's like
yes if you start i think whatever you
pay attention to
of course but as soon as you get into
that game where it's like right i'm
gonna
look for everything bad it's like it's
like doesn't mean you're bad but it
doesn't mean you're looking for it right
it's like saying that's what she said
once you start you can never stop so
once you start like looking for white
supremacy that is correct
yeah you can never stop and i think
that's kind of what's happened to these
people i think they're kind of losing it
did you guys see
roon gate yes negative so this is
another good example
of just like how stupid and insane
everybody is so
the cpac stage is what is it the
conservative political action conference
yeah they said looks like the nazi
was it called an oh doll rune or
something yeah it's like a nordic rune
have you seen this it's like a diamond
and then it goes like out and there's
like little wings i guess
i feel like every three months they go
look at this kind of looks like
you know they've had a few superhero
things where they said oh the thing
looks too much like the
ss stage and the other thing yeah the
eagle remember the imagery people are
always kind of saying the imagery looks
like nazis
and the nazis took the swastika from
like a hindu
it's a hindu religious icon the odel
rune is like an
we'll see how much uh uh youtube allows
you to to get away with all
right
uh tim i don't want to talk about my
personal problems that i've had with the
great corporation
google.com which you called them
google's not me
i was totally something tim would do
yeah and if if the people at google are
listening i appreciate y'all i love you
guys
so i'm trying to get rid of those
strikes we definitely so
so apparently cpac is getting cancelled
like like i mean i mean cpac was already
pretty canceled dude did you see that i
don't
know
spangled banner no hold on hold on we
got to talk about that i don't mean that
they're like shut down i mean
cancer culture canceled like they're
getting attacked apparently the hotel
wrote wrote a strongly worded letter
saying like we can't believe that they
used this imagery
as their stage in a week they were yeah
they were
from the moment cpax like almost
liberals were like oh they're still
gonna do this this year do you know how
mean we are now like they almost tried
to get everything they went for the
hotels and then the speakers and the
agents of the speakers it was like a
full
sea pack's like christmas to these
people it really is yeah
welcome back everybody i think we just
got booted and returned back
yeah um okay the stages some people
might not even even notice because it
may have just like stuttered and then
you say welcome back yeah we had a
little blink on the internet you can
hear that chime
yeah it's when it but we have
redundancies set up because you know
they try to keep us down it's two days
in a row are we back right now yeah we
are back i think
we're recording the whole time guess
who's back okay okay unnecessary
the cpac stage is a convenient shape for
a stage
i will say i don't agree with those bad
things you said about google when the
cameras were down the gamer word again
i don't know whether to complain about
the the corporate response to
these accusations or to complain about
the girl's performance of the star
spangled banner no why
oh my god it was so many different keys
she just kept changing keys
and there's a video of a guy trying to
play piano along with it
look at simon over here simon simon
cowell dude you got to watch judging
this woman's singing
it's so bad yeah so funny totally didn't
vote for her
oh my god no i gave her the x i gave her
the odell roon
i mean this girl's career wasn't like
skyrocketing if she's doing the cpac
anthony
listen listen listen conservatives are
not cool
nope that's that's always been a big
problem but but i say but to all the
conservatives who are watching
i i realized something with like all of
this cancel culture stuff and like going
back to some of the earlier stuff we
were talking about
ryan have you ever watched like what
what is that god flicks called
pure flicks pure flicks yeah you ever
watch like those old christian versions
of movies and like conservative versions
of like tv shows and stuff
it's like really low quality and just
like really poorly acted
yeah it's it's inverting now we're
getting
like conservatives are starting to make
content and it's getting better okay i
watched
bill o'reilly interview the insane clown
posse
when was that ten years ago so cool and
he was saying the exact same thing that
these people were saying he goes
you know you're this is harmful words to
kids
you know it's everything that they were
saying this shouldn't be available we
need
all of the stuff and it was 100 flipped
and you know the insane cl and they were
like
you know you're teaching your kids to
you know do all these bad things in the
in saying clown posse who
you said you're a big juggalo fan
but they were kind of like no these
people aren't as stupid as you
like that's it you're just looking for
the worst thing just the same way when
they go
oh look at uh some right-wing guy and
they go look at this thing you said and
you go you're just trying to find
something like that's not really what
they're about
i was trying really hard to remember the
lyrics to halls of illusion because i
was gonna
sing i honestly couldn't remember it but
you know after the world i could say
that
oh my gosh he's a bigger you know halls
of illusion i thought was actually a
good song when i was a kid
dude when i was like in grade six little
skateboard kid when they came out
they go in this one song i say f 93
times
i was like here's
a point i want to make right i'm
imagining like uh uh i used to
there was a channel in chicago that was
like the christian channel and they had
a bunch of cartoons that were very hokey
and like just not
good storytelling but it was the
religious message yeah it was like
the religion behind it made it good no
matter what i think about like the
static shock thing where they're making
him get his powers of black lives matter
and it's like watching
when i was a kid watching these
christian cartoons with like you know
like
christian man and it's like he got his
powers from reading the bible and
and praying properly and i'm like you
know what's you know what's
substantially cooler
than that version of static shock
jackpot's agent post yes
so much cooler it's it's tongue-in-cheek
it's like
it's like self-deprecating almost where
they're kind of mocking the idea
so this isn't as many lines like you can
like listen no one likes to watch things
when they know it's like
really being colored in the lines and
there's just
there's no transgression on it and that
could be like artistic that could be
political whatever it is
so when you completely know exactly what
you're getting and you know why you're
getting it
it's it's less desirable to watch and it
you know it doesn't catch cultural heat
and that's why
all of these places are having trouble
like manufacturing the energy to get
people to like their things
well i also think that it's like it's
it's what you were saying earlier you're
allowed to give me one teaspoon of
propaganda for every like cup of
entertainment or whatever yeah
but what happened what happens is you
the the problem with with giving more
propaganda is
the feeling i get is i'm watching
something and i want to be entertained
if i'm mostly just getting smacked over
the head with a lesson
well then i would rather watch like
reruns of american gladiators
and listen to uh bill hicks screaming my
ear about how i'm
you know you know an idiot for doing it
but it's more entertaining than
watching like religious content look i'm
not trying to rag on religious people
but i tell you when i was growing up and
i saw these like
i went to catholic school and they would
play these cartoons where it was just
like
you know just not good storytelling
but it was the ideology behind it well
so it comes back the idea where you go
okay what would it take for you you know
if someone has a belief like let's say
they're a huge fan of a sports team and
you go what would it take for you to
change sides like to not be a yankees
guy if they lost like if they didn't
make the playoffs 50 times whatever it
was
and they go nothing i'm to the death and
you go okay so i don't really need your
take on them then do i
yeah and i think that's what all this
stuff is if you go you're so in it it's
you know to the death and i'm ride or
die with this ideology
what if what if we're completely wrong
about the static shock thing
and it turns out that the villains were
all black lives matter supporters
and the villains are anti-fun we're just
like we're totally wrong i mean i got to
see the movie to
yeah coming to what it's a comic i think
they should run with that idea that's
the best that i can think of
i mean sprinkle some dangerous i got to
tell you it's probably going to be
the bullies were at a pro-trump counter
rally and cops will be bad
just sounds terrible but why would the
cops why would the cops tear gas the
trump guys
in the same comic like the comics trying
to make the cops bad guys the cops
have to protect the trump supporters how
did the bullies get super powers
i were you reading this have you read
the comic yet just the just the ones
they showed would you hate read it
no i would i would i would legit just
read it that is the one thing
of all of the you know you could make
fun of this group or that group and
people get mad at you
i did a comic sketch recently where i
had uh
three different comics it was that's
their culture and if you saw it the
superheroes one yeah youtube.com
comedy but then no but i i got probably
the most people mad ever that i included
different uh heroes from different
universes
of course gamers are the the number one
lobby right now because you had captain
america on the flash
and then i had them all fly and they
were like
dude people were fired up do i know the
actual truth and this is what happened
was sometimes it ain't like is it wasn't
even me being stupid i go
i looked at amazon to buy costumes and i
was like those are the three that kind
of look the best
you put captain america and the green
lantern together
and they all fly no one cares about you
offending
minorities or whatever oh no people were
fired up about that
cancel ryan long there's okay okay well
hold on hold on let's think
about it ryan long was the flash the
flash
could spin his arms really really fast
to create
wind pressure yeah theoretically where
were you in my comment section
green lantern can just legit fly so
you're good there and captain america
he tony stark gave him a um
a repulsor for his
shield and it allows him to fly yeah
i think so tim's got your back there you
got the hook now now now it
it is uh it is canon but it is i mean so
much of this stuff because even like i
see how fired up you are about this
story like it all kind of goes back to
the game
how many people say that gamergate is
kind of the uh you know the pinnacle of
the whole thing but
it's like the one thing that they're
like we can't have this one thing
like they're it's like okay fine all
your commercials are this
okay all the movies are this and they're
like we want to take your comics and
make them this too and everyone's like
you've gone
too far well it started with it started
with games
and there was a meme of a guy in a
military suit
with like a feminist tied up and he says
why did you make me do this i just
wanted to play video games
like the point they were making rather
extreme
is like if you just leave our video
games alone we didn't care what you were
doing politically
dude of course but then they were like
you had you know you know what it was
yeah i just want to play video games now
campaigning that's the meme i just
wanted to play video games
but so the issue is i think a lot of
this started because
when the blog era began there was this
pressure among these like
low talent midwit writers to produce
content every single day
if you write for a video game website
and it was the way to get publicity too
well right so check it out you come out
with a
comedy special and i write for a comedy
website i can only write about your
special one time
so what they do is when when a video
game comes out the video game
you know bloggers would write about the
game write about its release
write tips and tricks and then say now
what what do we write about no games are
getting released
we can't just have the website be dead i
can
oh there was uh a guy in the game and he
was he said um yeah he said
big in reference to a woman oh that's
fat phobic
definitely the content the necessity for
pounds and pounds of content
you know contributed to that's exactly i
mean decided the blog generator where
they just go
there's a uh transphobia problem in
halloween yeah yeah whatever it is he
throws a dildo at the wall
yeah and it sticks to us no that was the
old vice thing
yeah that's old vice mine's right right
right mine's the new blogs
all together it's so good yeah sticking
the things on the wall
and it's ryan long comedy yeah so so
basically
exactly you have a formula what was the
formula so there's uh
blank has a blank problem yeah and then
if you want to get if you want to snazz
it on anything yeah if you want to snazz
it up
you can but i included all the articles
that actually exist and then some guy
made the generator
wow and put it online and it was pretty
fun so basically you can pick any word
like i need social justice they do it
yeah yeah and they they really do it
they'll find anyone and then you go
reverse right like
there's a racism problem in the gay
community there's a gay problem in the
re
the community and they just do the whole
thing over and over and over again so
but it's so it's a big part of that like
with the content thing but then i think
also
there's this idea that it starts with
the
it starts with the thing but it becomes
about
making you agree to something so that's
kind of like you know let's say the
trans thing right
so it's always became they go a lot of
people
you know why did five comedians all have
their specials about trans stuff right
and they go
why do you guys care so much about this
and i was kind of having this argument
about
something that i could have talking
about anything so i was talking about
fallout boy the band and this girl goes
so fall out boy's a boy band and i go
they're not really a boy band like
they're just kind of a band like i don't
like them
yeah and i was like a boy band i think
like backstreet boy you know whatever
having this argument before i know it
i'm like dude they're not
you know i'm getting all fired up and
then it becomes like yo why do you care
about followed boys so much i go i don't
care about fall out boy you're making me
say something that isn't true
right now and that's kind of a lot of
this stuff gets there and you
get fired up and then they go what do
you care about this thing i don't care
about this thing
well that's the thing like so i i
tweeted about potato head
because ap said like mr potato head is
now regular potato head and then
everyone was like it's gender neutral
and i just tweeted how is this is stupid
like how is he even gendered anyway his
name is mister
like that's so dumb i don't even care
about the story but then some
some article took my tweet to claim that
i was an outraged conservative
oh angry and i'm like i didn't care
about this you know what so i decided
you know i'm gonna do from now on
i'm just going to tweet the opposite and
so i just tweeted i demand a gender
neutral potato
and then when when hasbro tweeted out so
do you see the tweet can you go further
you see the tweet from mark dice where
he responded to it saying it's time for
republican states to secede
so in response to potato head story he
tweeted and then all the leftists were
like they've gone crazy slightly
hyperbole so when hasbro announced that
they didn't actually get rid of mr
deadhead i tweeted it's time for
democrat states to secede
so it's like call me right wing then
yeah whatever
so now i just decided yeah you're
messing with them i'm just you know
uh michael malus tweeted because we had
ethan sipley on the show
and then he he tricked lydia into
bringing him oh my gosh
to what he texted lydia and he was like
talk about me
yeah he did it i said i learned
i learned from the best michael i
learned from from him how to tweet
properly
because his tweets are always you can't
tell
they're very opaque yeah you don't know
what he's saying yeah he's sort of in a
lot of times
is wrapping logic into weird places too
right
and like the the easiest example to
explain to people is when trump would
tweet something he would say we don't
deserve him
so you don't know if he's for or against
trump thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time